i try to take stock in the fact that we
do have the most divided congress
basically we've ever had
in our history um almost as evenly split
as it could be in the house and the
senate and for
somebody like kamala harris who is the
deciding vote the tiebreaker in the
senate
she has an enormous amount of
responsibility and i think and i hope
that she will weigh that responsibly
because it's going to be on her
shoulders
you know they're talking about
eliminating electoral college now that's
their big thing
and does she really want that on their
record you know eliminating all the
history and all
the positive things that that has done
to thwart
uh the you know the uh tyranny of the
masses the things that could have
you know if it weren't for the electoral
college we you know slavery would have
existed probably much longer dave
isn't that actually the cool part that
it's like there are all these
networks popping up you know right
leaning or conservative leaning networks
and i don't sense that
although obviously at some level there's
competition there's only so many ad
dollars to go around or whatever it
might be
but it's like there's the blaze there's
daily wire there's news max there's more
and more there's independent guys
there's the whole thing and it's like
everyone's kind of helping everybody i
go on everybody's shows
i'm happy to promote everybody and it's
like man we just need
more and more let's if i find a new
voice that's good i'm like
man come with me with me on this
adventure i'm with you 100 dave and the
way i kind of look at this
and uh forgive me because i have some
southeastern conference bias here
you know congratulations to alabama and
everything i'm a georgia
grad but i consider conservative media
almost like the sec like the elite of
the media
and you know you may be alabama and i'm
georgia here uh
but when it comes we might compete in
our league when the when the time is
right when it really matters like on
election night
you know we're going to be in position
to really have the best ideas because we
compete with our ideas
and i think you know in the long term
you know you ask
you know people of a certain age are
more conservatives you know
at the later end of your lifespan than
the younger folks it's because
conservative ideas
eventually do win out over time when you
have the
advantage of perspective and longevity
and history to look back on you realize
that the things that got us here to
where we are as a country have worked
and most of those things whether it's
federalism
or you know checks and balances those
kind of old school ideas
it's really conservatives that have
continued to talk about those things and
really defend
those principles throughout history and
it's very exciting because we have those
things for another seven days
well i i honestly think i mean this is
scary for a lot of folks here but
i'm reminded of many times in history
when we've talked about how bad things
could be i i try to take stock in the
fact that we do have the most divided
congress basically we've ever had
in our history almost as evenly split as
it could be in the house and the senate
and for
somebody like kamala harris who is the
deciding vote
the tiebreaker in the senate she has an
enormous amount of responsibility
and i think and i hope that she will
weigh that responsibly because it's
going to be on her shoulders
you know they're talking about
eliminating electoral college now that's
their big thing
and does she really want that on their
record you know eliminating all the
history and all
the positive things that that has done
to thwart
uh the you know the tyranny of the
masses the things that could have
you know if it weren't for the electoral
college we you know slavery would have
existed probably much longer dave so
these are the things they want to tear
down we know it's kind of symbolic at
this point
and i'm really hopeful while at the same
time skeptical that they actually want
to do this stuff because they know
based on what happened like you know the
supreme court for example that there are
unintended consequences and it usually
comes back to bite him in the ass
yeah listen i i i hope you're right
i do hope you're right but i actually
think they want to do
absolutely everything that they say they
want to do and the electoral college
stuff the pack and the court stuff
whether it's post impeachment of trump
like just
whatever crazy bananas thing someone
puts up there
i think they want to do all of it i just
see do you see any reason to think
is there anything in the movement right
now that
comes up as like a roadblock for you
that they're like oh well maybe they'll
turn around now i mean they are seeing
the cliff over there i mean maybe that
this one you think well
you know i i hope so i had mark halperin
on my show today
you know kind of looking at the public
opinion polling available on this
impeachment issue is pretty weak right
now but there are polls out there
that showed us the same thing as it
showed us last time when they were
talking about impeachment the country is
evenly divided on this
you know and i still believe in the
collective you know kind of
power of the individual of course but
you know the american public too and
there were a lot of promises made
uh about two thousand dollar stimulus
checks from the democrats
especially those who recently won those
seats in georgia
if they fail to deliver on that you know
i i think there's going to be enormous
blowback
from this country again because they're
being disingenuous about their true
motives
and the american public is a lot smarter
than i think nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer and joe biden
and kamala harris give them credit for
and again and that's why i'm optimistic
still at the end of the day
dave is because we still have you know
75 million people in this country
who appear you know sane and you know
which side i'm talking about which
quoted
um and again i don't want to pretend
like i'm a partisan here but when you
look
uh at the comparison it's a stark
contrast and it's it's
it's cons it's hard for me uh to see
how people went the other way sometimes
but again that's just my opinion i guess
i can say that here
in this form no well i'm curious though
how do you balance that on a day-to-day
basis like when i do your show it's
pretty obvious to me that
you're a profes like you are a
professional newsman do you consider
yourself a traditional journalist still
no because it's obvious to me that you
have opinions and you're not afraid to
say them
but you are presenting news i think
there's almost an expectation now from
the audience not to give your opinion
but to be honest about where you're
coming from and i always talk about this
isn't not necessarily my opinion it's
more or less my perspective
you know giving people some insight on
where i'm coming from you know i grew up
in the deep south but my parents
are from the northeast i almost you know
i consider myself a first generation
southerner
you know even growing up in the 80s and
90s
catholic in the deep south with northern
parents you'd have friends and they'd be
somewhat skeptical of
what you know are you carpet back what's
going on here that type of thing
um but again you know it it it's
a diverse kind of background to have and
a different way of thinking at things
and that's kind of just always shaped my
perspective so but you know people
expect you to to kind of be honest
with them where you're coming from on
these things so i like to
say i do two things here i'm going to
lay out the facts for you and then i'm
going to tell you
why specifically we chose those set of
facts because
i have a limited time for my show so
there are only so many facts i can
provide in there
and there are other news outlets that
focus on other facts
but these are the facts that i think are
the most important facts and those facts
come
you know based on my history where i
grew up
what i believe the books i'm reading the
movies i'm watching and so
i do try to give the audience insight on
those things
so they have kind of perspective on
where my perspective is coming from and
that
you know i talk about this with my
college journalism professor all the
time david huczynski who used to work at
nbc news
he is admittedly a liberal and we argue
about politics all the time but
when it comes to the practice of
journalism you know the rules are still
the same at the end of the day
trust your sources attrib you know give
attribution to where your information
comes from only choose sources
that are really trustworthy tell people
the truth what has happened
you know and don't speculate too much
and you stay within those lines
it's not hard i mean it is hard it's
difficult but
you can do both dave give people the
facts be honest with him about what's
going to happen you know
don't be afraid to call him the
president-elect when you know it's going
to upset the audience because
they might be upset with you for a day
or two and some people might change the
channel
but come january 20th when i was honest
with the audience about what you know
historically and constitutionally
the limits were for what actually were
going to happen and that
you know linwood might not be right long
term when you're when you are right
you know they they gravitate back
towards you and they respect you
for being honest with them and you know
that's what you're able to do with your
audience
that is what i hope the internet still
provides you know you're still on
youtube
thank god for that um you know i think
you're about to cross 1.5 million
followers on youtube and
youtube would be nuts to take that
platform away from you
because it would you would really upset
or piss off i can say 1.5 million people
so
you know just like i have faith in the
overall population of the country you
know i have faith in those 1.5 million
people who follow
who follow you on youtube and that they
would pick up the phone or do something
to force youtube to make sure that you
still have this platform
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell